علماء الآثار خالية من الطين
والمياه العكرة تحفة فنية من
الماضي البعيد تمثال برونزي لصبي
يعود تاريخه إلى أكثر من 2000
عام من
الحفريات على مدى السنوات الثلاث الماضية في
هذا الينابيع الساخنة القديمة في سان
كاشانو ديفاني في توسكان هيلز.
إلى السطح ، وجدنا
فقاعة من الوقت يقود البروفيسور جاكوب
الفريق الدولي هنا ولا يزال
مندهشًا مما وجدوه أن
العملات المعدنية الأولى خرجت بدون أي فساد
كانت مثالية ، وبعد ذلك ببطء كانت
واحدة ، كانت اثنتين ، تم تعليمها كان هناك
الآلاف و  ثم كانت التماثيل
مؤثرة للغاية بالطبع ، حيث
يعود تاريخ القطع الأثرية إلى
القرن الثاني قبل الميلاد المحفوظة بطريقة صحيحة من
خلال مزيج من الطين والمعادن.
أجزاء معينة من الجسم على أمل
أنه من خلال الاستحمام في تلك المياه ، فإن
الآلهة ستشفي أمراضهم
في وقت يرتفع فيه مستوى R  كانت أوم في حالة حرب
مع الأتروسكان ، السكان الأصليين
للمنطقة ،
اختلط الشعبان بسلام في الينابيع
بحثًا عن العلاج الصحي والخصوبة
في مختبر ترميم تديره
عالمة الآثار بوزارة الثقافة الإيطالية أدا سالدي ، وأظهر
لي بعضًا من تلك العروض
بما في ذلك الشبه البرونزي  من
الأعضاء الحيوية
يمكنك رؤية أصغر التفاصيل
تقول القصبة الهوائية والرئتين مع جميع
الأوردة والشرايين والقلب
والحجاب الحاجز والكبد والطحال
والأمعاء
وأقدام وأرجل برونزية تم
العثور عليها أيضًا في الوحل
حتى الآن أكثر من 6000 قطعة نقدية  تم
اصطيادها من الطين بالإضافة إلى تماثيل الرؤوس البرونزية
وغيرها من الأشياء
،
حيث كانت مهمة سيمونا بوتسي المخضرمة في إدارة ترميم الآثار الإيطالية
هي تنظيف الآثار
ومحاولة الحفاظ عليها
، لم أر قط اكتشافًا مثل هذا
أخبرتني به
عدة ينابيع أخرى في  المنطقة
لم يتم التنقيب عنها بعد في
الطين والمياه لم تكشف بعد عن كل
أسرارها القديمة بن ريدمان ابن سي إن إن
كاسيانو دي باني إيطاليا